80 % des québécois parle le français et
les séparatistes veulent que le québec
devienne une nation francophone
indépendante
il croit que même sous le dernier
français ce sont les anglais qui possède
l'argent le pouvoir et la puissance
extrait d'un documentaire de lohan est
produit en 1974 quatre ans après la
crise d'octobre on souligne ces jours ci
les 50 ans de cette crise dont une des
causes profondes
c'était la disparité économique entre
les francophones et les anglophones du
québec mathieu guillon est ce qu'on peut
dire que cinquante ans plus tard les
travailleurs francophones ont comblé
leur retard en termes de rémunération
ils ont certainement gagné du terrain ce
que nous disent les chiffres bruts giral
c'est que les anglophones continuent de
gagner des revenus de travail supérieur
aux francophones en moyenne de 14%
mais il faut tenir compte de l'effet
montréal c'est à dire les mâles les
anglophones se retrouvent
majoritairement ici à montréal il ya des
universités donc de l'éducation et des
salaires plus élevés aussi par contre le
cyrano à regarder l'effet net de la
tribu linguistique c'est à dire en
tenant compte de l'âge de l'expérience
et de l'éducation et à compétences
égales les revenus de travail ne sont
pas différents entre francophones
unilingues et anglophones unilingues ou
bilingues au québec
cependant il ya une prime de 10% pour
les francophones bilingues
donc en termes économiques c'est
rentable d'être bilingue
autre donnée observables entre 1970 et
2000 le statut économique des
francophones a bondi de 13%
est ce qu'on voit depuis une vingtaine
d'années eh ben c'est une degert
diminution c'est françois vaillancourt
de cyrano qui affaire qui a fait ce
graphique qui a établit ses statistiques
et on observe un plateau en effet on les
côtes là dessus je pense qu'on arrive
probablement un certain plafond dans le
tissu économique des francophones je
pense que le débat prend maintenant à
être comment conjuguer bien aiguillé
faut se rappeler que la majorité des
francophones de maternelle ne parle pas
anglais au québec encore ou ou si c'est
pas du 51/49 maintenant comment on
compte quelque sort avec un québec
francophone
et donc est ce qu'on peut conclure
clairement que le sort des québécois
francophones s'est amélioré en tout cas
plusieurs facteurs ont favorisé leur
essor depuis des années 60 70
il ya l'éducation la fuite des
anglophones fortunés après la crise
d'octobre et l'élection du parti
québécois en 1976 les politiques
linguistiques et l'accumulation du
capital
ça allait très clair dans les mains de
francophones d'entrepreneurs
francophones et on se souvient de ce
maître chez nous de jean lesage
il voulait libérer ce qu'on appelait le
peuple canadien-français et l'économiste
de l'uqam pierre fortin dit
mission accomplie quand il compare le
niveau de vie du québec par rapport à
l'ontario bas le revenu par habitant
il y plus élevés quand on tient compte
du coût de la vie
comme quoi selon lui et ma le problème
est réglé les gens sont empoignés avec
leurs vieilles rengaines sonné pour un
québec est toujours un arrière des
jantes neuf thèmes scolaires gpe romande
et qu' on est revenu du parent né nous
mais au dernier rang des provinces
canadiennes sauf l'île du prince édouard
mais je ferai et demain je vous parlais
de la propriété de l'entreprise des
changements importants depuis 50 ans de
steinberg à métro très intéressant mais
si mathieu au revoir